Welcome Back everyone
it's Charlie this is my new Fantastic Four video
Marvel just made a bunch of big announcements
about the movie in Marvel phase six so we'll break
it all down I know there are tons of questions
about what's going on with the characters in
the MCU what's going on with Dr Doom because
we actually know a lot about what's happening
with Dr Doom in the 616 Main Marvel Universe
but he's starting in a different movie later
this year that's right we're going to get some
Doctor Doom pretty soon thanks to Black Panther
wakanda forever I'll explain that later in the
video because Kevin feige said their whole thing
was doing something different with a new movie
than they've done before so it won't be like
a rehash of the original Fantastic Four movies
and real big reminder that the Disney plus Day
event is happening in less than a few weeks and
they'll be dropping a bunch of Marvel trailers
for the upcoming Disney plus Series in the next
year Star Wars series and announcements like even
more Fantastic Four News so of course I will do
videos for all the trailers that they release
and announcements be sure to subscribe to get
all that it'll be like Comic-Con part 2 trailer
City it'll be awesome but the biggest news you've
probably been seeing in all your feeds is that
finally replaced John Watts as the Director of
the new Fantastic Four movie with Matt shackman of
all people who you'll probably remember from One
Division so it looks like Matt shackman is going
to be doing the movie now he's a great director
he did an awesome job with one Division and it
is still to this day one of the most popular
Marvel Disney plus series next to Loki this is
him talking a little bit about the characters
just talking about Marvel in general it blew my
mind as I pitched me the concept for the show
more than just because the idea is outrageously
fun and new but also because it felt like it hit
all the parts of my life I grew up being on shows
from the 80s like Facts of Life Different Strokes
um Growing Pains Etc but have also directed a
lot of you know large-scale spectacles so the
idea that there existed a project in the Marvel
Universe which I'm also an enormous fan of and
dressed up like superheroes from the Marvel comic
books when I was a kid until they told me I had to
stop the idea that I could combine all these
things that I've always loved into one crazy
project it was almost like too hard to believe
it's too good to be true it's cool to see how
big a fan Matt shackman has been of just marvel in
general since the 1970s for pretty much his entire
life as he mentions those old shows like Facts
of Life Different Strokes he actually started
out as a child actor in the 80s and then after
he finished school transition behind the camera
producing and directing so that's how you end
up doing all this big stuff you've probably been
seeing the cast of Always Sunny posting a lot of
memes about how they should be the new version of
the Fantastic Four because Matt shackman directed
a bunch of Always Sunny episodes maybe we'll get
some Always Sunny cameos in the movie supposedly
finding the new Fantastic Four movie director was
one of the most important things that Marvel was
working on this year in the background because
apparently Kevin feige was looking for a director
who was strong enough good enough that he didn't
have to babysit the set himself while they were
filming to make sure that everything went all
right because if he didn't realize it a lot of
times they'll find directors from indie films
who don't have experience doing big Studio films
and Kevin feige himself will actually spend a ton
of time on set sort of shepherding and babysitting
the movie Kevin feige is one of those people that
says that he doesn't really like to sit behind
a desk like he has an office he does have a desk
but he doesn't like to sit behind it so when he's
not in the office or he's not meeting with writers
rooms about upcoming projects he's usually on
the different film sets of all the movies that
they released each year when they're working on
them so like one division for example was kind of
like a trial run for Matt shackman he did such a
good job with the episodes that he directed that
that put him in line to direct on the Fantastic
Four movie we just saw John Krasinski fulfill all
of our fan casting dreams they actually did the
thing and he played Reed Richards in a version of
the Fantastic Four in the 838 Illuminati universe
but you probably saw the news that John Watts the
Spider-Man director inside the MCU he's done
all the Spider-Man trilogy so far Spider-Man
no way home most recently was originally going
to be directing the movie announced by Kevin
boggy a couple years ago and finally I'm happy
to announce a film about one of the truly iconic
Marvel families in fact Marvel's first family
Fantastic Four we're working on a feature now
and it will be directed by the director of
our recent Spider-Man films John Watts but
he actually just left the project a little while
ago because they conferred that he's going to be
directing Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland Zendaya
pretty much everybody's coming back they're going
to be picking up where they left off in Spider-Man
no way home with the College ARC for Spider-Man I
got a lot of questions during my doctor strange
videos about who remembers what about Spider-Man
and Peter Parker now because they referenced
Spider-Man several times during Doctor Strange
2 later in the timeline but none of them know
that Peter Parker is underneath the mask they
just remember that Spider-Man has done a bunch of
stuff they also revealed one of the other reasons
why John Watts left the Fantastic Four movie is
because in addition to Spider-Man 4 he's going
to be directing one of the Star Wars live action
series it's going to be called Skeleton Crew it's
going to be a spin-off of the Mandalorian like
book of Boba Fett like John Favreau says it'll
take place in the Mando verse as they call
it that's what they're calling the larger
Mandalorian Universe of shows now they haven't 100
confirmed John Krasinski is their man coming back
as another Multiverse version of the character
R.I.P to the 838 Universe version but supposedly
he is the leading candidate right now it would
be great to see him get to play a badass version
of the character who is actually the smartest
man alive like no more meme posting about him
being the smartest man alive This Time It's For
Real supposedly The Cameo scene that he did in
Doctor Strange 2 was meant to be a trial run
so to speak just to see how fans responded to
it and just to test out what his powers looked
like on screen just to serve as sort of a trial
run for what it would look like if he used his
powers we got a little bit of of him like he
stretched a little bit but mostly it was Scarlet
Witch turning him into spaghetti and him coming
through portals the whole thing with the portals
is just teasing the whole Fantastic Four subplot
with them traveling around to alternate universes
using Quantum energy the same way that Ant-Man and
the WASP introduce Quantum energy the same
way that King the conquer who is related to
Reed Richards also uses Quantum energy to power
his TBA portals that's why they look so similar
to the portals that Reed Richards was using and
speaking of them doing an MCU version of Doctor
Doom this is Sam Raimi and Michael Waldron the
writer talking about introducing the Fantastic
Four to the MCU and how they specifically wanted
to reference Dr Doom when they were introducing
this version of Reed Richards the detail of the
teleportation device he uses to get into the
scene is something we took from the comics that's
Dr tunza Dr Doom's uh time door you see it's all
connected all the way through the timeline from
Kane the Conqueror at the end of the timeline all
the way to Ant-Man and the WASP Avengers endgame
Iron Man what they did traveling through time
and then Reed Richards now in another alternate
universe is it's all about all these alternate
universes all the incursions and the lead up to
the secret Wars we actually already know what's
going on with Dr Doom and the MCU on the 616 Main
Earth he's featured briefly like very briefly
as part of the Black Panther wakanda forever
storyline and I believe he's only going to be
referenced very lightly in the movie like he's not
a big character in the movie or anything like that
like maybe at the end like a post-credit scene
or something like that will tease that Dr Doom
was kind of pulling the strings from behind but
he's supposed to be the person in the MCU who's
funding This research looking for more vibranium
so he's the person who's effectively paying Riri
Williams using a bunch of different sources
to hide his identity in the comic book version
of Doom War he just outright invades wakanda
trying to steal their vibranium kind of like
Ulysses claw he basically wants to use that to
upgrade his armor all of his doombots all this
technology like the way they explain in the
MCU vibranium has a billion different uses
so of course everybody wants vibranium but in
The Illuminati's a38 Universe this version of
Reed Richards was meant to be like the full
fan service fan casting payoff because they
had a full family from the com Comics they
didn't mention Johnny Storm or the thing but
they were meant to be alive in this version of
the team and when I say paying off fan casting
theories the writer claimed that this version of
Sue storms that they referenced in the movie was
meant to be Emily Blunt John krasinski's real
life wife I think the deeper cut in this Cameo
scene was confirming both of his kids were alive
too Franklin Richards and Valeria Richards and
Franklin Richards is probably the most powerful
character that Marvel's ever introduced in the
comics just because of the way that his powers
work he can create entire universes out of nothing
in fact at the end of The Secret Wars ARC in the
comics Reed Richards winds up being one of the
people to fix the Multiverse like repopulate
it with all the different universes that were
previously destroyed using Franklin Richard's
power in a couple years ago when Kevin feige said
the intention was for them to do their Fantastic
Four reboot movie as Marvel's first family he
was actually talking about the original family
not the traditional nuclear family that you're
used to thinking of when you think of family like
Kevin feige was talking about the original family
of four adult superheroes Reed Richards Sue storm
the thing in Johnny Storm but basically they're
going to be trying to set up the main version
of the team the main version of Reed Richards
and all these MCU movies and he'll share a lot
in common with what's going on with King the
Conqueror the TVA Quantum energy along with Hank
Pym Ant-Man and the wasp in their use of quantum
energy a character who does a lot of research
and technology and crosses between different
universes frequently all in service of continuing
this big storyline with the incursions and the
Secret Wars teaser a lot of you also confused
about the familial connection between him and
King the Conqueror yes they're related but they're
very very distantly related so Reed Richards and
Kane the Conqueror are kind of like very very very
distant half-brothers so they only share a little
bit of genetic material they already said we're
going to be seeing a bunch of different versions
of King the Conqueror in different movies like
different iterations of the character from the
Multiverse it sounds like Marvel is going to use
him as sort of the focal point of the incursions
because of the Kang Multiverse War like they're
gonna say that the Kane Multiverse war is part
of what's going on with all the incursions so even
if Kang isn't going to be the main villain of this
new Fantastic Four movie it sounds like will be a
lot of Easter eggs for him too but everyone posts
all your theories for this brand new Fantastic
Four movie in the comments and who do you want
to direct it I'll do more videos for the movie
when we learn more about what's actually going
on I'll do more videos for the movie when we
get more announcements and we have all those new
trailers coming soon I'm in the middle of doing
videos for all the She-Hulk episodes so I'll put
links in the description for all those episodes
my next big one will be for House of the Dragon
episode 2. be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that and everyone click here for
my house of the Dragon episode 2 trailer video and
click here for my Full House of the Dragon episode
1 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!